now back to the big political news out
of Washington this morning some
Democrats call the acting Attorney
General's appointment a constitutional
crisis and even some Republicans say
it's imperative that the Muller
investigation be allowed to continue
Paula Reid covers the Justice Department
for us and she's with us this morning
Paula good morning what does this mean
for the Russia probe there are a lot of
concerns with inside the Justice
Department that would occur could try to
limit the special counsels investigation
he's now the one who has final say over
any charges that are filed and he'll
also be the one who will decide as long
as he's in that job whether any final
report from the special counsel is made
public and before he came to become
sessions chief of staff he made a lot of
public comments they were very critical
of the Special Counsel investigation and
suggesting its scope could be limited
and right now and the president is under
increasing scrutiny in that
investigation still negotiating whether
or not he wants to answer questions at
writing or in person it could be very
beneficial for the president and his
legal team to have someone like
Whittaker at the helm
could he be nominated as a permanent
replacement for Jeff Sessions it's
possible at this point is unclear
whether or not he will be the permanent
replacement the president made a very
unusual decision here he appointed a
chief of staff to become the acting
Attorney General there's a very clear
line of succession at the Justice
Department so the fact that the
president went for him that has raised
some suspicions inside the Justice
Department sources I've spoken with they
view Whitaker with suspicions they
believe he is a political opportunist
and there are concerns about who he's
working for whether or not he's working
for the American people and federal law
enforcement or whether he's working for
the president and Paula what's the
status of rod Rosen Stein who used to
oversee the Muller investigation he now
no longer does because the acting
Attorney General hasn't recused himself
the way Jeff Sessions did so what
happens now to rot Rosen Stein he
continues to be the Deputy Attorney
General usually that's not a very
high-profile job but actually he runs
the day-to-day operations of the Justice
Department he will continue to do that
but he's obviously had something pretty
significant taken out of his portfolio
here but depending on who is ultimately
put into the attorney general job who
can get confirmed and where
not the Senate and everyone else is
comfortable with that person taking on
the Russia probe he could potentially
get it back well it was reported
yesterday Paul that he had a scheduled
meeting with the president road rod
Rosen saw him talking about do you know
anything about what happened at that
meeting well we know he was at the White
House we do not know if he met with the
president but I will tell you he is
there almost every day for routine
meetings again he is in charge of the
day-to-day operations of all produce all
federal law enforcement as the number
two at the Justice Department we don't
know what they talked about but I was
told by sources inside the Justice
Department that it was a routine meeting
all right Paula thank you so much for
your reporting now back to the big
political news out of Washington this
morning some Democrats call the acting
Attorney General's appointment a
constitutional crisis and even some
Republicans say it's imperative that the
Muller investigation be allowed to
continue Paula Reid covers the Justice
Department for us and she's with us this
morning Paula good morning what does
this mean for the Russia probe there are
a lot of concerns with inside the
Justice Department that Whitaker could
try to limit the special counsels
investigation he's now the one who has
final say over any charges that are
filed and he'll also be the one who will
decide as long as he's in that job
whether any final report from the
special counsel is made public and
before he came to become sessions chief
of staff he made a lot of public
comments that were very critical of the
Special Counsel investigation and
suggesting its scope could be limited
and right now and the president is under
increasing scrutiny in that
investigation still negotiating whether
or not he wants to answer questions at
writing or in person it could be very
beneficial for the president and his
legal team to have someone like Whitaker
at the helm
could he be nominated as a permanent
replacement for Jeff Sessions it's
possible at this point is unclear
whether or not he will be the permanent
replacement the president made a very
unusual decision here he appointed a
chief of staff to become the acting
Attorney General there's a very clear
line of succession at the Justice
Department so the fact that the
president went for him that has raised
some suspicions inside the Justice
Department sources I've spoken with they
view Whitaker with suspicion they
believe he is a political opportunist
and there are concerns about who he's
working for
whether or not he's working
for the American people in federal law
enforcement or whether he's working for
the president and Paula what's the
status of rod Rosen Stein who used to
oversee the Muller investigation he now
no longer does because the acting
Attorney General hasn't recused himself
the way Jeff Sessions did so what
happens now to rot Rosen Stein he
continues to be the Deputy Attorney
General usually that's not a very
high-profile job but actually he runs
the day-to-day operations of the Justice
Department he will continue to do that
but he's obviously had something pretty
significant taken out of his portfolio
here but depending on who is ultimately
put into the Attorney General job who
can get confirmed and whether or not the
Senate and everyone else is comfortable
with that person taking on the Russia
probe he could potentially get it back
well it was reported yesterday Paul that
he had a scheduled meeting with the
President Roh dry-rot Rosen saw him
talking about do you know anything about
what happened at that meeting well we
know he was at the White House we do not
know if he met with the president but I
will tell you he is there almost every
day for routine meetings again he's in
charge of the day-to-day operations of
all produce all federal law enforcement
as the number two at the Justice
Department we don't know what they
talked about but I was told by sources
inside the Justice Department that it
was a routine meeting all right Paula
thank you so much for your reporting